well Asian markets have been rallying
after President Trump said he's delaying
a tariff hike on Chinese imports on
Twitter the president said both sides
have made quote substantial progress in
trade talks the world's two biggest
economies have been locked in a trade
dispute for months with the u.s.
accusing Beijing of intellectual
property theft and of limiting American
access to his markets the new tariffs
increase was set to come into a force on
March the first while speaking shortly
after his Twitter announcement the
president said he was looking forward to
reaching a trade deal with China we just
left a big meeting with China and we
just put out a statement and we're doing
very well with China it was a long
weekend they decided to stay for two and
a half more days they'll probably be
leaving late tonight they're going back
and if all works well we're gonna have
some very big news over the next week or
two and it's really been terrific I tell
you that whole relationship has been
outstanding we put ourselves into a
position of strength for the first time
in about 35 years or probably a lot more
than that but China has been terrific we
want to make a deal that's great for
both countries and that's really ok
joining sound studios Clifford Cooney
spent 15 years in China joins us from DW
business morning Clifford could we be
seeing soon a new trade deal between the
world's two biggest economies do we have
any timeline for this we don't have a
timeline as such but I think we I think
things are looking very positive because
I think both sides need a big political
win so they're very keen for it to
happen
well whatever about the substance of the
deal of course that's going to be the
big question so I think they're gonna
make it happen they're gonna try and
make it happen around the timeline
perhaps of the Mara Lago meeting with
that with Xi Jinping traveling again to
Trump's home base there yeah so I think
it'd probably be built around that okay
do we have any you said there could be
some key pieces to this that we're still
waiting to find out about any Inklings
of what they may be well I think I think
they will what you do is China will be
forced to buy agricultural products
we beans soybeans for example and things
that will affect us farmers you know
which are also good for the headlines in
the political capital I think on key
areas they're still very far apart um
basically Donald Trump and once China to
behave like a regular market economy but
China isn't a regular market economy so
there's a little communist command
economy isn't basically yeah and
obviously with Chinese characteristics
as they say but it's still very much
it's still very much acts on its own
terms okay important for America as well
as some protection of intellectual
property that's everything from Disney
to books to films will we see any any
progress there I think we will see some
cosmetic advances but a lot of it is how
American companies for example have to
act in US Court arias are in Chinese
courts and which are still still tend to
favor Chinese firms so I think that
there's gonna be a few areas where it'll
be very difficult to find agreements
okay so these discussions are actually
touching on Chinese law and and how
court procedures are conducted that
certainly is far-reaching in terms of
what negotiators are up against um yeah
how do these talks fit in with with a
huawei and and you know the the 5g
technology and what the future holds
could there be some agreement and and in
something that has connections to state
security and and issues like that
yeah Huawei it's been pretty central to
this I think he said that he said that
he will revisit the case of Milan Joe
the CFO of Huawei who's in in Canada
waiting possible extradition to the US
so obviously and this is a big bugbear
between the two countries so I have a
funny feeling that he will possibly try
and and and politicize that which is
obviously has ramifications for the rule
of law but it's it's a Huawei and the
security concerns they're a lot of
people have been are worried that it
could use it could compromise your
security but it could be that that
there's a softer approach now to Huawei
which which would be interesting in
itself briefly if you could have these
talks fit in with the North Korean
summit that's coming up in a few days
well I think there's a big political
element to this and and you know if he
scores a what looks like a win on the
trade talks
it would dovetail very nicely with the
with a win in with king kim jonghwan in
in hanoi so I think they're very linked
in terms of how the big picture looks ok
Clifford thanks so much for that
Clifford Coonan from the business
you